Luke Tom Natan Jake here with the
outdoor boys YouTube channel and today
we're going to Florida we've got some
pretty awesome stuff planned we're going
alligator hunting shark fishing catch
crabs swim with manatees wrestle pythons
it's gonna be pretty awesome but first
we've got to drive 15 hours one hour
down 14 to go and it's been
bumper-to-bumper traffic
[Music]
Jacob Jacob why were you screaming all
night
[Music]
all right
little good morning guys it's another
beautiful day we're starting off with a
beautiful breakfast I've got an apple
brioche dip and french toast batter then
I'm frying in butter and of course we've
got bacon Oh dick if you want some of
this well it is a warm if rainy day and
we are going to go to church well we got
done with church but it was a mixed bag
this one right here
decided to be funny to run away from mom
and dad and run around the chapel
screaming well so far today we slept in
ate a delicious breakfast went to church
hung out by the pool played chess on our
phones this is everything a sunday
should be especially when you drove 18
hours the day before other than going to
church we didn't leave the house all day
long but tomorrow is gonna be pretty
awesome we're gonna hit a tackle shop
bright and early do some fishing and
I'll see you guys tomorrow what would
you do if there was a child right in
front of you it's a beautiful Monday
morning and it's not even 9:00 a.m. and
the kids are already in the pool which
is a perfect 93 degrees I need to do
some fishing let's go get some tackle
then I've got some frozen lady fish
frozen mullet I got some Chum and some
stuff for Sheepshead including we got
some live shrimp here
you ready buddy
yeah oh you got a fish he'll you put him
back in the water little bit weak dad is
a proper sheep set look at those
chompers for eating barnacles and
oysters there you go buddy
nice
oh yeah that's a gap top seal but how
many fish like a bajillion right 13 well
let's go to bed and tomorrow we're gonna
do this again okay yeah nothing says
family life like a minivan and a full
bike rack all right baby come on yeah
hey I thought they were there Kiwis but
they're not wow it smells like the
underside of a lawn mower yeah it does
is the Nichols botany tour where we see
things we don't know and stomp on them
[Music]
[Music]
it's one of the best Christmas Eves I
could remember you guys having fun we're
gonna go to bed here in a little bit and
we will see you guys on Christmas
morning he told me what day is it
[Music]
you guys excited for Christmas present
[Music]
right Dave you ready
me and Jake are gonna go do some fishing
there you go just pick some oysters off
the the seawall here broke one open put
the guts on a hook just like a big
booger we're gonna fish with that
[Music]
yeah here's your Sheepshead Ben say
click subscribe well good morning and
you know what day it is
I thought hunting day are so excited
unfortunately a little Jacobs not coming
with us
all right we're in the swamps of
Southwest Florida near the Everglades
National Park and we are looking for
pythons girls are looking for tilapia
and Oscar armored catfish other invasive
fish
the old alligator cider road I'm driving
up and down on these roads and hoping to
find a Python sunning themselves on the
pavement or on the shoulder of the road
driven around the car an awful lot but
we want to get off the beaten trail it's
our first sighting look at this the dead
Burmese python that's got to be excited
how about you Tom just scanning this in
Bank mint and the shoulders of the path
is anything that looks like a snake well
I got a little work out there and time
we got a mud bath we're in another spot
we're Python hunting here in the dark
oh it's 6:00 a.m. and we had a bit of a
rough night's sleep - say my legs are
sore is a gross understatement the gas
station picked up some breakfast and
Advil
it really hurts to walk
I just pulled over this little canal on
the side of the road just saw an armored
catfish swim off look I got him look at
that I got him yeah there we go oh look
at this guy
noises he's making
roll him on to his other side there
there you go Becca what do you think
[Music]
smells a little funky
what do you think of that that is all of
the meat off of that entire cabbage
is that tasty yeah you like that hmm not
bad we're gonna meet up with a guide and
we're gonna try to catch a massive
alligator Tommy here loves to eat
alligator don't you it's really tasty
what do you think tom is this cool right
here yeah we should always Drive like
this right oh man this is gorgeous look
at this country oh yeah Gator down there
yeah how do we dump
any mop here will you wait on me get
both hands out here on his name you've
got him all right you gotta go tell me
Oh y'all look at me Tommy let go here we
go
yeah don't let go he's gonna he's gonna
get us up there you go now back straight
up Tommy all right Tommy you want you
want to see mama freak out we're gonna
send her a text picture of that mom mom
would just put text it back oh my with
some exclamation points we're being very
safe baby don't worry oh we got some
ugly weather coming
oh there he is popped up
we're trying to keep him out of that
grass well over there yep yeah we're
totally beat we're keeping it all
sending him back now that was right up
there with catching those eight-foot
sturgeon man that was fun though Magic
Mike here is going to show us how to get
some Gators all right let's go get
number two what do you think Tommy is
this one of the coolest hunting tubes
you've ever been on these alligators are
really skittish I'm trying to use my
lights to film but I got to be really
careful because it's scaring them off
you help videotape Tommy
you went to the right
holy mackerel that was a big Gator it is
late and these guys still got a long
drive to get home so they're gonna take
the Gators back to their place put it in
the cooler and then where I'm gonna come
back in the daytime and i'm gonna film
them skinning it up and the process in
it we're gonna go through all that well
good morning and welcome to another
wonderful day today is jacob's birthday
hey Jacob how old are you can you see -
yeah - we're gonna go to church we're
gonna celebrate jacob's birthday we're
gonna relax a little bit alright boys
get buckled in boy had a lovely time at
church and someone gave us a bag of star
fruit oh one of my absolute favorite
fruits and I'm excited to eat these is
this another early morning and we're
getting up to go process that alligator
and unfortunately there's about to be
tears because Jacob got his boots on he
thinks he's coming
there we go will you that
this is what we got left over we got the
hide the back like strip of hide Jame
tail meat and some little bits that I
got off the legs wearing Gasparilla
Island with my parents well Lincoln
Ethan skaters we got the better now
[Music]
we are going to cook up some alligator
[Music]
I'm riding me a little bit of pork oh
yeah yeah yeah here you guys go
guys can you guys can eat alligator
nuggets in the pool you guys enjoying
eating alligator nuggets in the pool
hear it a little bit up and start
rigging up my gear I'm going shark
fishing tonight
[Music]
that is perfect shark bait right there
you ready to go shark fishing
there we go we got two beats out in the
Sun is setting
I'm not going to do this very long and I
don't think I'm going to rebait in the
dark but we'll see what happens
[Music]
[Music]
whoa that is the big shark
there we go
the water I'm not a hundred percent sure
but if I had to bet that was a sandbar
shark
it looked about six to seven feet long
and over 200 pounds he looked a bigger
than I was that guy was stocky and angry
we've had a lot of fun it's been about
an hour and a half but we're wet a
little cold a little hungry and it's
getting close to bedtime so we're gonna
reel this rod up and call it a day oh
it's another beautiful day at our last
full day here at the rental house we're
gonna do a little fishing and then we're
gonna go on an airboat ride and some
swamp buggy stuff and we're gonna have a
great time got your own mangrove snapper
boo hey all right we're off for another
adventure we're gonna go on a swamp
buggy tour and an airboat ride and I'm
pretty excited I think the boys gonna
have a really good time with this Beck
are you ready for this yeah
[Music]
look at the size of those things
yes you guys this makes gives me a good
carpet you like that
[Music]
hey boys was that awesome
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go oh you're holding an
alligator dance did you have fun yeah
we're back at the house and it's time to
make up some alligator tacos then we are
gonna play in the pool for a very long
time and begin the slow process of
packing because tomorrow we're leaving
to go crabbing up near Crystal River
Florida and then we're gonna do swimming
with manatees and some other stuff but
we're getting out of the house in about
24 hours
alligator tacos with fried alligator
cilantro lettuce on a tortilla some
macaroni salad and fried hush puppies
tell me like those alligator bites oh
you gotta tell you this pool is nice
it's 93 degrees it's screened off from
the bugs and the screen and the trees
make it shady enough we haven't had to
put sunscreen on the kids at all this
trip which is really really unusual for
these little pasty white butter balls
[Music]
well guys we had an excellent day the
kids are in bed we are all tuckered out
and tomorrow we are checking out of here
it's our last day here at the house and
we are in the checkout process I have
never got this car so fall let's see if
we can shut the door oh that worked it's
all in the button well we're just
getting ready to leave and the boys just
had their first experience with biting
ants Jacob and Nathan were playing with
this and you can see all those crazy
ants came out I hear Nathan start
screaming and I run over he is just
covered in biting ants and we stripped
him naked and there were ants in his
underwear there were ants up his shirt
he was just covered and Jacob got a bit
of it too but Nathan Nathan's full of
tears he got bit all over you can see
they're just ants all over the place and
the boys are standing right there Jacobs
you put your hand in an ant pile look at
that oh yeah they got you good
[Music]
yeah you did fire and attacks the side
please mated all right guys let's let's
go crabby for hearing Crystal River the
sun's just about to set and we're gonna
go on a very unique Charter we're taking
the kids out crabbing at night with Nets
you guys ready to go catch some crabs
are you guys excited to go out at night
you think are you excited all right guys
we're hunting blue crabs so apparently
what we're gonna be doing is dipnetting
here's a short net for somebody that's a
little smaller okay you're okay
if you see one out in the distance like
floating don't try to you know just
point them out to me and we'll make a
circle and we'll go right back after oh
here's one there's bitting up in G he'll
let go shake oh there we go oh well
there's one right there see him Nate
right there right there
get him get him Oh Oh Nate you so close
spider in him oh there's one right there
he's coming toward you babe what
happened did the crab pull you in yeah
you were reaching for that one that was
just a little too far away that's all
right buddy we'll learn from this day
won't you snuggle up with momma chill
she'll take care of you okay guys our
dear buddy right there right there
[Music]
sneaking get that getting put it down
low over the top of them here I'll chase
them into your net you got it
oh right there that's that salami
again you get you got him you got him
we're gonna try no he went through that
he wiggled right oh no I do have oh it's
all the way through there we go
guys we are having so much fun I'm gonna
put all the information about this
Charter in the video description if you
want to check this out check out Florida
crabbing charters calm here in Crystal
River Florida you havin fun tom
I want you hand me a jig oh he's got
long arms be careful that yo you're that
guy whoa oh yeah look at how blue his
claws are to there you know this is
pretty awesome but it's so late let's go
to bed well it's quarter to 11:00 and
we're getting checked in as fast as we
can because we're going swimming with
manatees tomorrow morning we gotta get
up at 6 a.m. to do that well good
morning and apparently I thought it
would be a good idea to put a 7 a.m.
manatee trip the morning after doing a
late-night crabbing trip
oh we're exhausted well we're back here
at Pete's pier in Crystal River and
we're gonna go swim with manatees got my
aquatic full-body Spanx on yeah look at
that you're looking good there buddy all
right head funnel mom
Crystal River in Homosassa star the two
big places to swim with manatees and
you're in Florida and Crystal rivers by
far the more popular the two that's why
you get up so early one that's easier
find humanity's but oh so there's quite
a few turbo to do this you try to get a
better spot at winter time is the best
cuz when it's cold
manatees come into the springs and
there's more manatees debt see yeah
clear that is look at all the little
fish and everything put that underneath
your arms there and just wait for dad
right in the water
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we saw about four different manatees you
got a swivel act next to them they're
all sleeping and it was it was really
pretty cool you Becca got a touch one
and if you guys want to do this we're
gonna put links in the description guys
did you have fun 826 miles or 12 hours
14 minutes to home let's go if you like
this video don't forget to check out the
outdoor boys YouTube channel where we
have hundreds of videos just like this
and don't forget to click Subscribe so
you can see other great videos every
Saturday morning hit that belt button
you'll get notifications thanks for
watching
[Music]